good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast it is a Tuesday and I
can't believe it's only a Tuesday cuz it
feels like a Sunday that's how long this
week has been and it's a snow day
New Yorkers I got my moon boots on I've
never been so prepared for the weather
like I never even looked outside but
just that's so funny that you say that
yesterday so many people mentioned to me
and I saw on the toasters people were
talking about the snow in New York and I
felt like a kid when I woke up out of
bed I've checked out the window to see
if you know if we were gonna have to go
to school today right we did because
there wasn't how much snow on the ground
but I got to wear my ski coat my moon
boots
I really never felt so comfortable and
weatherproof I'm always like wearing
satin shoes and wearing rice always me I
literally never peek my head out the
window cuz it's like you know what the
weather is what it is and why let it
dictate my life I didn't know it was
like flurry season outside and it's
actually so dangerous and slippery to be
in shoes like this so I mean I had a
whole busy day planned I will be going
home after this you need a pair of moon
boots
yeah I actually actually no I do have
snow boots and they're mad cute from ugh
good oh nice us weirdly don't have
traction on the bottom like it's more
slippery than any but they're ugh snow
boots they're not like the ugh like
boots but you would think ugg boots like
could get you through the snow there no
they can't know they're like soggy yeah
they really can little to no protection
I'm a big moon boot Moon Boot advocate
less Moon Boot I'm thinking the Moon
Boot community um speaking of weird
things we say Jack and I recorded a
patreon episode yesterday that was very
very highly requested it was basically
just a rundown of all the weird [ __ ] we
say where it got started that the
origins of speech and and and snitch s
and steen and all of your questions
means Mackenzie v Alice Lee there wasn't
enough time and honestly Jackie talks
the entire episode because she really
makes up all these weird [ __ ] like I sat
there and just listen because I learned
I don't even know how we came up with
visions team you know right it's all
there we tried to recount everything as
best we could and honestly my memory was
coming back to me I think it was my
favorite episode we've ever done it was
all coming back to you now I was crying
and then towards the end I got started
on how counselor snitch was born and the
cambers Italian camber American camber
and I just like it was like 10 minutes
of I couldn't stop talking about how the
American camera is watching YouTube
videos in there
so she knows how to do it for councillor
cinch when she goes out and it was just
really curious to see if like the
audience was following because honestly
I was barely following but for the most
part the reception was good they wanted
part two so that's what we'll do yeah
there are still more terms that I have
yet to define kawaii I never I never got
to that so they target like the
distinction is like okay there are two
there are words that we own and we made
up the phrase can't enchant like we own
that [ __ ] till the day we die but a lot
of people think that like we invented
the word stand which we did in but we
just like we use it so much and for a
while it was just like a dark Twitter
word that like only people like in
fandom Twitter used but now it's in the
mainstream yeah or it's like you just
use it so much that you've co-opted it
like shook we didn't already know we're
sugar Sweden event no but you know we
just enjoy saying these things so
definitely check out the episode
patreon.com slash morning toast we'll
have a part 2 soon and then we're gonna
do some wedding content it's gonna be a
good month for the patreon yeah you
should become a patreon member wasn't a
grocery tote how you feelin one day
closer I'm feeling like just ready to
get this show on the road totally you
know yeah I liked in my tables yesterday
so hard which was hard but easier than I
thought it would be like there were a
few random people and then there was
just like a few like people that had to
be together like tables it just made
sense but then it's like one over or one
below you know I never really realized
that like being a single at a wedding
you know at a couples table it's like
say you're friends with people and there
are all couples in you're a single like
do you be at their table or I'm giving
some people opportunity I'm creating a
few singles tables right I mean I think
like it depends on the type of person
like I think I would rather be at a
wedding if I was alone like without been
with my friends and their husbands then
at a table of people like I kind of know
right alone without been meaning that
you're married oh yeah for sure
okay but like as a single person I still
think I'd rather be with my friends it
depends what kind of single person you
are you trying to get out there right
need some people you've never met but
we've also done a really good job of
like merging all of our friends like my
friends know your friends and your
friends know you came for the new
confirms know your school friends like
because we have so many likes teeny
events that we just like invite the
safety break you so there's a lot of
crossover like I feel like you have it
easier than some people might know I
have it very easy like I can really
mix-and-match with anything just like
steamed um yeah that the circle of
Steen's it just makes it really simple
like I don't deal with like Margaret
earns Olivia Sterns and no one would be
like no what are we doing but you asked
me like four specific people like where
I put them and I had to go back into my
Google Doc of and like I just brought
back like some of the worst memories
like last day I was shaking before bed
like just thinking about it
really yeah not not not that the table
part was hard it was just like the
wedding planning part was hard yeah it's
it's a [ __ ] it's actually really
surprising how like far how close to the
actual wedding day you do the tables
like you think like you need to do the
tables months before to have the things
printed no taste like a week yeah and
you can't even do the months of work
because people don't people are still
are sleeping Olivia got an RCP to her
wedding like a week ago right no yeah we
opened it on Friday it was yes it was
huh yeah anyways um interesting I went
to such an interesting restaurant
yesterday I'm like was it an interesting
restaurant that was well interesting you
know in restaurants always doing like
concepts and [ __ ] you know and it was
this restaurant called chefs Club where
they basically like changed the
restaurant every three months so
everything Mundt said literally clean
out the kitchen there's not like a crumb
left and they bring in like new chefs
with Heppell who have like an audience
and I went to this Israeli chef last
night with kosher meat and like honestly
I'm constipated because I eat so much
meat I never eat meat yeah and it was
like friends and family of like the chef
and so I knew so many people I was like
literally a socialite I was like oh hi
dinky bring some meat home for Theo and
I know I ate it all but um there were
bones and I should have brought that
home but I always get worried about
giving Theo human food because I've been
told that the seasoning it it's not the
bone or like the meat that's bad it's
like the salt cayenne pepper whatever
you put on it that is really bad for
Theo stomach yeah he looks like wash it
he's so precious and they like it I
don't think he can handle it you know
the song delicate by Taylor Swift was
actually written by about the oh he's
been the source of inspiration for so
many songs and he's just really
contributed to the arts in that way and
we can't thank him enough
he had a bath yesterday finally he the
biggest knot in his tail I got a haircut
for the wedding when I'm like stroking
Theo like before bed and there's not
like obviously she want to run my
fingers through them and take him out
and like he wants to kill me but then
you're excited cuz you're cashing those
knots very farm check exactly what else
what else just like getting my life
together you know yeah busy busy time
busy as a bee gotta get been a
Valentine's Day you have to having the
hardest time saying
I just need to show up at a bunch of
stores and hope they have the answer for
me but it's like I made it till you say
literally sent him a picture of what I
wanted reasonably priced and you know
for Hanukkah we said no and he sells
struggling I still sending me like oh my
god I mean for Hanukkah we set a price
limit and actually it was the best gift
I ever got and same for him like Moses
yeah I got an iPad which I didn't even
know I wanted and now for tor it's like
rice I'm in a thousand no it was like a
it was 500 oh how much is my pad I think
it wasn't one of the new one I think he
went over the price of it no he didn't
yes it and I've had and I got him like a
cool like duffel bag from supreme like
for his like gym bag you know and he
uses it all the time
there's no way you guys stayed within
the price limit yeah well mine was I was
actually below 300 oh yeah I'm a bargain
shopper anyways yeah I have to do that I
just have so many little things to do
like you know my eyebrows my eyelash
before shhhhht oh make borscht coder
soon board well your pillow fresh has a
borscht recipe you mean I don't really
cook and I can't but I only can when
they make it as easy as they do for with
hellofresh
they should make a Theo specific borscht
they either come worse or they need to
collab with Theo for the best bore she'd
ever had and you know what I think it's
I mean soup is easier to make the most
things so if you want to cook at home
but you don't want to cook at home
here's what you should do
hewill fresh is fresh pre-measured
ingredients with easy-to-follow six-step
pictured recipe cards are delivered to
your door each week in a special
insulated box
it's literally cooking for dummies it's
incredible you spend less time meal
planning and grocery shopping so you can
get that time back to do more of what
you love sitting on your couch and
eating all meals come together in 30
minutes max call for less than two pots
and pans and require minimal cleanup
that's the hardest part man the clean up
not down agreed maybe I'll cook
hellofresh for Valentine's Day
oh that's cute and then exact do the two
dishes that they generally yeah maybe I
would throw those into like okay the
full package but if you guys want to do
a take advantage of hellofresh special
offer for 2019 get $80 off your first
month by going hellofresh comm slash
toast 80 enter code toast 80 so that is
hellofresh comm slash toast 80
eight-zero and enter code toast 88 zero
I've done it a couple times it really is
shockingly simple and you the cards are
so funny like it don't for someone like
me no it's genius and they've come these
little lunch bags and it's just like but
it's premium meals no it's good stuff
it's good stuff it's everything I hoped
it would be you know it's everything you
ever want and everything I ever need is
it here right in front of you this is
where you want to be this is where you
want and I'm kind of hungry I'm always
hungry but I know it can't be hunger
this week this isn't the week for her
looking so small really yeah like tight
and fit oh my god thinks that's what
I've been going for it um I'm gonna
stand up and well I have three more
workouts before the wedding oh we're
doing big method today I'm doing two
workouts tomorrow because I'm doing live
method today and tomorrow but then also
there's an ariana grande SoulCycle
tomorrow that I just have to go you
wanna be sore at your wedding
no but then my last day of work am is
Wednesday
also musical Monday yesterday no one
told you it was the steamiest class of
all time there was not one song even
when he started to play song I think I
was dying I was like I need a break I
need Chicago yeah don't rain on my
parade oh you kidding it was crazy
he played he opened with Circle of Life
Lion King um we were just like Hanuman
it was so good he played two greatest
showmen songs it's so annoying like when
I won that was good but not that good
um the one from Dreamgirls the big one
we dream girls hit the one that Effie
sings and I am Telling You um oh you
mean the one Bianca Ryan sang and her
audition for America's Got Talent
yes that her winning number that one
speaking of performances for for one of
the arm songs he plays hand jive from
Greece oh that's good you're like born
to hand-jive baby that's really good
yeah Greece is good like Greece is like
you think of it as like the basic [ __ ]
of musicals and then they give listen to
the soundtrack baby [ __ ] premium [ __ ]
tell me about it stead
speaking of performances that you just
can't live without tickets to the
Foxwoods in Dallas second shows go on
sale presale started yesterday
sold a good amount of tickets but
there's still some left so at the end of
the show right before we hop off I will
post a link in the trusters
and I my Instagram so if you're not in
the toasters group you can still get it
so that's what you're here for
just wait give me like an hour yeah at
the end the show yep
no no never no no no is it gonna be a
live situation of course it's a livin
let's live show and it stutters lives in
it okay so I believe without further ado
it is now let me check my watch
hmmm yes it is officially time to
deliver the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast okay
first story Miley Cyrus attends isn't it
romantic premiere as Liam Hemsworth
recovers and gives Instagram Premium
captions premium content and Premium
captions Miley Cyrus has husband Liam
Hemsworth back Liam Hemsworth back on
Monday the nothing breaks like a heart
singer and every cover singer of every
song ever attended the Los Angeles
military oh but he could be the one
singer right Hemsworth's Hemsworth's
it's a hard thing to say yeah the
Hemsworth his know like Hemsworth's
new movie yes apostrophe s ' right Liam
Hemsworth his new movie now that isn't
it romantic on his behalf is the 29 year
old actor recovered at home from kidney
stones according to people so proud of
my hunky hubby at Liam Hemsworth and his
newest movie isn't it romantic he
unfortunately wasn't able to attend due
to health reasons but he's recovering
and taking time to rest sighs Oh
unfortunately not able to attend because
he's at home with a broken heart just
because people are realizing that his
wife and Shawn Mendes are perfect
together right and because nothing
breaks like a heart yeah um she's so
cute her Instagram caption is so funny
she looked so pretty that movie looks
horrible horrible like maybe one of the
worst movies ever made no but of course
I have to see it of course no but it is
like a Razzie contender none of that
it's like the front-runner for the
Razzies no it's like it was made to be a
Razzie award winner like I feel like
sometimes they make movies like for
Oscars you know you're not even to make
the movie no but this was for the
Razzies no and I was reading that award
sure she deserves it's about time Liam
Hemsworth is so much better than that
movie like it's just white why does he
let him in jail bro oh she's in it she's
in it that's horrible like rebel Wilson
is not too good for that movie yeah
Priyanka Chopra is too elevated
Liam Hemsworth is too talented yeah
islands of ining rebel Wilson can like
they're perfect now slumming it China
welcome score big hmm and and I don't
mind watching them fail but what seemed
like Liam Hemsworth in this role or
Priyanka Chopra like it's gonna make me
sad no it totally and it's just the
concept is so stupid and it's like it's
such a played out concept like you wake
up and you're Freaky Friday or whatever
like it's such a played out stupid like
concept for a movie and they made it so
much worse so it's like scary movie or
disaster movie right it's like a parody
of romantic comedy movies but like
that's not like what the top tier of
actors should be doing yeah yeah it's
like so much money was spent on this
movie and it's just looks so sick that's
someone who looks like Liam Hemsworth
isn't that movie like seeing them great
someone from Hallmark that like Rite Aid
because they kind of resemble a
Hemsworth brothers right and if you're
like not wearing your glasses and you're
watching the commercial you might think
it's a homo no but maybe I'll watch it
that gets cute that's the same thing
they're they're hoping for over at
Hallmark HQ right but anyways that was
sweet of my like I'm sure it was a big
deal that he couldn't go to his premiere
and she was like I can smooth this over
and like she went and like Instagram did
and like everyone was happy where's like
she might not have done that and now
everyone's talking about the premiere in
the movie the morning toast is talking
about it whereas we might not have done
that no I definitely wouldn't be talking
about them if they just showed up on the
red carpet together like what are we
gonna be like they walk the red carpet
together that's not a new story mate I
just can't believe that like after all
these years after all Miley went through
like she was so crazy like she just made
it back to her long blonde hair and Liam
Hemsworth like that is a true Hollywood
fairytale it really is she was her crazy
like isn't it romantic is it yeah you
know it is like it's so you should make
a movie about them totally pop star
honestly like without like this suicide
and addiction its various stars born no
seriously
yeah it could be called back to my roots
yeah or the climb back to Liam no that's
like wait she's terrific like life's a
climb but the view is great a little
long but or like the final song that
sounds like a funeral no or maybe she's
become
a song honestly it's kind of hard to
think of a name for this particular
movie just cuz it's so complex right so
many you know can't be tamed until she
could the tamed one that's good we
couldn't stop until we could what the
hell's up we can't stop
oh yeah yeah I got it I got it I got it
I got it
Liberty walk nailed it that album is
literally like the greatest ever it's
like an album I can go back like year
after year and just still really love
and appreciate and you know what every
time I hear it I think about them sorry
he could be the one
Oh duh oh my god no no he was the one he
is the well how about this so one easy
good thinking about that album that's so
transformative transformative is that no
matter what place I am in my life like
when I listen to it I'm immediately like
drawn back to the moment when I first
heard the album we were at camp yeah
it's what I always think of like that
year I was like getting boobs you know
like it was just like a growth moment
for me yeah I love and album that's just
transport you I love an album that gives
you boobs okay next
oh wait someone also came up with a good
name in the caption in the comments Emma
no sorry Megan you'll always find your
way back home you can change your hair
you can change your clothes and that's
exactly what she did
but hey oh my god that song is totally
about her you can change your mind you
could change your you could change our
hair and you could change your clothes
you can change your mind that's just the
way it goes you can lay view and buy and
you can say hello but you'll always find
your way back home it's such a good song
such a good move you can change your
smile you can chase your dreams you can
never win I like this oh my god she was
cheating her smile Oh totally
she was so nuts with that hair she
remember she was so nuts and it's like
what'd you think of her being nuts just
like VMAs twerking on Robin Thicke that
wasn't even that crazy compared to Miley
Cyrus and her dead pets no compared to
like Carney bees music video we thought
Miley was crazy for like bending over
Robin Thicke and twerking on him did you
see that music video with all the assets
yeah and you were in it yeah isn't it
you had me you haven't done your new
greeting in a while you know what I'm
still sore from the first time I did it
and it's you know this is a morning show
I can't you guys can only expect so much
physical activity for me
seeking of cardi B she has deactivated
her Instagram account after Expo two
filled rant following her Grammys when
cardi B is at least for now quitting
Instagram but not before she gets in the
last word following criticism that she
was undeserving of her best rap album
Grammy win something said everyone says
that like Eddy say that about every
award no but it's like everyone could
say someone deserves an award and then
one person on Twitter is like hey shut
down to so-and-so right following
criticism yes totally like of course
there's always gonna be a dissenting
opinion like welcome mr. America maybe
that's why he won um and some social
media drama where she was pinned against
her nemesis Nicki Minaj by the bTW
Network the bow de hielo was being shady
as [ __ ] do you see what they did yeah
okay the boudic yellow rapper got he
didn't explode a brand on her Instagram
the video which was captured by an
account has since been deleted and was
followed by cardi deactivating her
Instagram entirely it's not my style for
people to put other people down to
uplift somebody else she begot in the
clip referencing the digby team meet at
Nicki which she said was quote being
dragged by her lace for an after cardi
cardi's Grammy win that's not my style
and that's not what I'm with she said
adding I don't support that though I've
been taking a lot of [ __ ] today I'm
seeing a lot of [ __ ] today and I saw
a lot of [ __ ] last night and I'm
sick of this [ __ ] I work hard for my
[ __ ] album she angrily stated
the rapper continued her rant by
reflecting on the reactions from last
year's Grammy results cardi and two
nominations in the Best Rap performance
and best rap song for her track phone
yellow but did not win for either one I
remember last year when I didn't win for
bodek yellow and everybody was like
cardi got snubbed she were called now
this year is a [ __ ] problem my album
went to time platinum and every chart
there are so many blanks I don't know
what the words you know she's probably
cursing we're right so I don't know what
it is yeah I'm gonna it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
and every chart that there was my album
was always top-10 number one album as
well defending this year's win cardi
noted how she worked her ass off and
spent endless hours in the studio
despite being pregnant with her daughter
culture no I mean I didn't actually as
someone who you know is a critic and
he's always complaining that stuff on
Twitter I didn't see any one saying that
that she wasn't deserving a Best Rap
Album what I stopped was like everyone
was really happy for her I mean I'm sure
there's like stands of Drake or whoever
else was nominated be like drink do it
but like whatever
that doesn't count she didn't really
have to address this because it wasn't
overwhelmingly like negative but I
fled in the beginning she dressed the
video like even though her Niki of beef
she's like I don't like the beach either
that and that was like really like weird
of them yes it was especially because
her production company her something is
a sponsor of the BT Awards and she
pulled out yesterday after they tweeted
that good it's thirsty it's thirsty and
it's just unnecessary it's making drama
but like they finally both calm down and
like a word shows like don't jump in on
the drama you know like networks at like
imagine if the Grammys was releasing
state you know it's weird that were BC
yeah it's weird so I hope she comes back
to Instagram and I just wish like she
this is why somebody's like shouldn't
even be on Twitter like there's always
gonna people be people who have negative
things to say but I mean overwhelming
response was positive like I'm sure of
Kacey Musgraves text Twitter like she'll
be depressed I'm sure there were people
whose Christmas grades the country so
yeah it was like when BEC one like right
this Claudia Austria was tweeting me the
[ __ ] is back right but you know what it
is opportunity for us to listen to some
of Beck's music which I haven't gotten
around to doing since 2010 but I still
plan to I know she really like shouldn't
have addressed it because now I'm like
oh let me go see what people are saying
you know anyone I didn't hear about it
before so it seems unnecessary was
undeserving of the award apparently like
when I didn't think that way before
right and she said something right
before she deactivated she put up a post
being like I thought this is what I want
it you guys can have it I think in terms
of like the fame which is like you know
she's her label yeah I mean everyone
says it it's like we're off you're like
I'm to be famous and it's like they're
trying to tell us it's not no it's like
every famous person tells us like you
don't want this but we don't listen no
we need it I know as someone who has
like a very small modicum of fame I'm
here to tell you it rocks right I wonder
like what the level is like I feel like
beanie Breck's is still enjoying her
fame what point do you not enjoy it
anymore I think it's not more so a point
it's really I feel like has to do with
like what type of person you are and
like how you were raised like if you're
just the type of person who's like go
with the flow like easily persuaded like
addicted personality like it's very easy
to get caught up in the and like
whenever I'm at something cool and I'm
like living for it I'm like oh this is
how people get addicted to drugs like I
love it you know
yeah but then like you go home and you
go to sleep and like you you you come
down from that high but some people like
never come down right like emotional
around them
like let's go yes oh it has a lot to do
with like who you surround yourself with
and just the type of person you are I
think yeah yeah I agree
okay next story we haven't spoken about
this in a while but it's just an update
around the salaciousness of the pictures
in the text messages that have been
leaked from one chef faces multiple
specify spoke about it I think on Friday
with Margot when it was a National
Enquirer thing really because I watched
the show in it oh then maybe we didn't I
was like going back and forth but I'm
like jeez Margo even know who definitely
says you know well she does because she
warders a lot of stuff - I'm Miriam yeah
she's his new girlfriend no III mean
Margo likes another man but I don't know
if she if she likes Amazo some type of
man no I don't think so either she
prefers a man with some hair right and
you know I'm not gonna say it more money
no but no okay okay what the hell are
you sorry tell me later no it's just
like just move on with this money no
wait no okay multiple suspects including
Lauren Sanchez being proud as leakers of
the baseless nude pics okay right here's
the thing the thing is Jeff Bezos nude
photos and text messages salacious
messages have been leaked
who the [ __ ] leaked them it's they're
not leaked they're threatening to leak
no the text messages were leaked the
text yeah everything not the penis pic
no they have been linked someone has
them they're not releasing them because
like that is illegal I'm fairly certain
hmm but how did they get them oh I don't
know how are we reading his text
messages that he wants to read the news
Miller with amaz Amazon founder CEO Jeff
Bezos doesn't have any privacy like
nobody does multiple moles are being
probed as potential leakers of Jeff
Bezos his dick pics as the feds join the
investigation into the publication of
the billionaires passionate private
messages to his mistress Lauren Sanchez
Lauren's brother la talent manager
Michael Sanchez is seen as the main
koper behind the sensational story but
we're told it's expected that there are
other sources who sent saucy Bezos texts
and photos to the National Enquirer
Bezos lover Bourne is believed to have
shown her forwarded the photos to a
close to close friends to brag a source
tells us Michael was never even sent the
dick pics I can't imagine anyone wanting
to send her brother a dick pic to page
six sources said Michael is the lead
leaker although another source says of
the revealing photos there are multiple
possible suspects clearly
boring show these photos - we're
girlfriends for entertainment okay so
first of all just this is giving me
seriously like Monica and Ross Geller
vibes like inappropriate sibling
relationship like first of all like
we're sisters and like if I ever got a
dick pic which like I don't think I've
ever gotten one like intentionally like
I've never asked for what I get the
right if you got it a pic from someone
neighbors been like what I show it to
you no that's [ __ ] weird and it's
even weirder for a brother sister to do
it okay and here's the thing unless his
phone was hacked which I don't think
that it was there's no evidence that it
was and plus he's like Jeff Bezos I
think he has a hack-proof phone yeah
then there's only one person he was
sending he's figure it's you and that's
Lauren Sanchez so it starts and ends
with her so even if Lauren Sanchez sent
it to her brother and her brother was
the one who leaked it Lauren sentence is
still the one who leaked it is still the
molle vibe I mean she is still the mole
woman I can't believe that like in
today's society there's still people who
are sending nude it's like for so many
reasons like it is the dumbest thing and
like back in the day like when cameras
were blurrier and like there wasn't as
much like like you know 6g hockey vibes
like okay you could get away with and it
was still really [ __ ] stupid but like
this oh my god
yeah I mean it's like he was probably
just so excited he's like you know he's
dating someone in the new digital age
that he helped create and he's like I
want to do what the kids do this is
literally the definition of biting the
hand that feeds you like Jeff Bezos
created the digital world and the
digital worlds slapped Frankenstein you
know created this monster can't control
it your Achilles heel my Achilles heel
because the internet is the thing that
made him great but it's also his
downfall it's also the thing that's
literally going to destroy him so and
the fact that everyone's blaming it on
the brother is making me feel like it's
not the brother right like you never I
mean it's not the brother it's Laura
it's someone in the Sanchez camp unless
there was someone else get in the dick
pics I don't care who Lauren sent it to
Lauren is the mole are you ma'am Lauren
still together right like I'm sorry Jeff
besos if you're watching it's like you
can't trust her obviously not look what
happened
you sleep with dogs what does it get
fleas you lay with the dogs you get
fleas and you know what your dick is
please now I can't wait to see it and I
can't wait to see a picture of it I meet
you obviously that's why I know you're
not on Twitter I don't censor what guy
oh is that where it goes down I know
you're not on Twitter but like if you
are looking for like a nude photo of
someone
like when those pictures of our Lando
bloom on the paddleboard nude that's
different
then then a hacked photo a hacked
private photo he went paddleboarding
nude as a celebrity he he must have you
found public but yeah like I you know
that's different than like Jennifer
Lawrence's phone personal photos beat up
green I just wanna say I'm a type of
person that I do not go searching when
someone's nudes get leaked that's really
nice of you I try not to but like
sometimes curiosity gets the best of me
and it's really [ __ ] up and I don't I
don't agree with my own behavior but you
know I don't share it that's good yeah
yeah that's helpful anyways I just try
not to you know perpetuate that I mean
if Jeff Bezos is dick I don't want to
lose someone like if they oh my god
Jason Momoa you would have to look but
on Weekend Update when he was like when
the picture was loading I thought it was
Venus yeah it really looks like that
totally I mean he is like a little penis
he is I just I wonder what he's going
through right now and like who can he
trust and I really hope that he's not
with Lauren st. Joe's right now I know I
mean that would just be so she's a
genius how we figured it out how are you
not know like he's a genius but he's so
dumb this is just like this is so funny
because it's like you could be the
smartest man in America but you're still
a man and you're so stupid like this
would never happens like a woman CEO you
know now never happened to Melinda Gates
you know no it would not this one ever
happened to Sara Blakely exact Bethenny
never never but she has her own [ __ ]
okay next up in some new Zee News Fox
her love newsy news socks host says
quote he hasn't washed his hands in 10
years did you see this story yesterday
no Fox News host Pete hagseth has said
on air that he has not washed his hands
for ten years because germs are not a
real thing speaking of sounds like he
was being a good snitch oh my god but
does he shower yeah her gloves in the
shower is he intentionally not cleansing
his hands or just like not washing his
hands after the bathroom I believe it's
just not washing his hands every
bathroom speaking on Fox and Friends
hexa said the infectious microorganisms
did it not exist because they cannot be
seen with the naked eye i inoculate
myself added the Harvard and Princeton
graduate his walk stream after co-host
EDN
Jedidiah bila made fun of him for eating
leftover pizza quote my 2019 resolution
is to say things on air that I say off
air he added we live in a society where
people walk around with bottles of
Purell in their pockets and they
sanitize 19,000 times a day as if that's
going to save their life he said I take
care of myself and all that but I don't
obsess over everything all the time okay
just want to say I don't use hand
sanitizer I don't believe in it but I
wash my hands I think 20 times a day um
a blue public reaction he said it was
ridiculous how people took things so
literally and seriously so that their
heads explode this guy sounds like he's
just like clickbait he like wants to
make a name for himself at a network
yeah being a freak yeah I don't know no
or like he really just thought this was
like normal when he went to Harvard and
Princeton and like okay honestly like
I'm feeling really good about the fact
that it again to Harvard that's what
they're teaching you sick sick sick sick
stuff that's disgusting I mean also does
this guy live in New York does he take
this subway like I feel like the amount
of times a day you wash your hands is
directly correlated to where you live
like if you live in New York you have to
watch friends at least five or ten times
a day
like I wash my hands every time I step
into my home from the outside oh well
really yeah I wash my hands all the time
like they're so I wash my hair every
time I use the bathroom and the rare
occasions when they just like feel dirty
do you know anything yeah or when I do I
make up but usually I'm right after a
shower when I do when we go I got it
interesante everyone has their own
things but I've never heard of someone
like not ever washing their hands except
for snitch and Peter
that's disgusting is he have a wife I
don't know I don't know anything about
him never heard of him before maybe
that's why now we're talking and I was
going to talk about something he's
trying to make a name for himself in
morning news it's working I think there
are really people who like just don't
want I mean I know of some other than
snitch um Dana
fine you know I'll say it she goes wash
your hands and she only washes her hands
in the bathroom when there's other
people in there so that they like me
think she's normal honestly I kind of
feel that it's good I don't think public
bad I don't wash my hands like for other
people like if I don't nobody without my
hands yeah you need to cut them up but
you also don't wanna be the girl like
walking straight from the stall out like
then people know you don't want your
answer you're disgusting but why
wouldn't you want to wash your hey
sometimes you know you just see her in a
rush you didn't you've wiped everything
was clean like I didn't do anything bad
like it was fine oh my god no I would
have somebody sometimes you're just in
there changing your pants you know
fine that's different if you go in to
change your undies or something like you
change your pants changing my undies
pants you want to change it from your
leggings into jeans you have an
important meeting um you know I might
wash my hands on my way out just his
muscle memory and you know I touched all
the stuff around the bedroom I touch the
knob I got a lip liner it's a chunky one
that's like not really gonna do anything
let's see I mean I literally haven't
even been noticing your let I ordered
Kylie's yesterday so he'll be coming
they said by Friday okay you got to get
your [ __ ] together like before the
wedding like you know I mean I'm getting
my makeup done for real and I'm just
gonna tell the girl Courtney my [ __ ]
just be like I love her I'm gonna
Courtney help me out like she always
helps me like when I buy my eyelashes
off you should have seen her face she
was like cuz she's been doing me for
like two years she knows I had good
lashes and she's very familiar with your
face she's gonna be so excited to see
her new lip so I sat down and I was like
and this I was like Courtney I don't
have eyelashes she said what are you
what are you talking about and I showed
her and she was like the lord she had to
do like single and she literally did
like eyelash implants transplants now
I'm enough to show her my lips and I'm
always telling her I actually every time
she does my makeup I'm like always
eating so I'm like I'll do my own lips
it but this time I'm gonna have her do
it well I still don't know where my lip
ends and my skin begins you know I mean
either and you need to do it keep its
bow but you know I don't have that like
you have a very defined Cupid's bow like
Rihanna and Taylor Swift yeah I feel
like that's something you can definitely
get done oh my god that seems so crazy
if you look back at pictures of Taylor
Swift like she has had the strongest
Cupid but like since she was born
Rihanna - but Kim now has like a very
defined like v-shaped Cupid's bow and I
don't think she had it yeah when I go
back to her he's going to ask this is
how people get I know what's so funny
cuz that might meet and greet like
everyone was coming up through there
like we've been doing it for years like
you they're like you're gonna like in a
week
be like so upset that you need more I'm
like [ __ ] the next day I was like it
cuz the swelling went down I'm like I
need more this ain't gonna kite just
really what wonder if Ben would have
noticed if you hadn't said something no
way and now every time he kisses me he's
like there's so much bigger like you are
just saying that because I told you I
was thinking about just like not telling
him cuz like he's like so like just
nobody know he was like but you
beautiful you gonna change and I'm like
that's sweet but like please yeah you
shouldn't I said if I can't do that I'm
gonna stop shave my legs and get
axes okay am i meeting natural okay
that's not like what you see been not
gonna like it at all
totally except I camera I've actually
been shaved my legs a lot just because
I've been showing my legs a lot I'm sure
my legs again tomorrow
brave cz I know without a spray tan what
is what's the bravery call for just you
know a celebrity outing very fun time
yes but I do keep up with the armpits oh
my God my itchy armpits problem has
gotten so bad it was definitely my do
trying to say so just like an organic
geodesic took hope Ari
Jackie [ __ ] you'll snap the wrist
since the other cope re I had no idea
what you were talking about we're in
Miami check is it's like chapstick that
she just covets hey chaps well it's a
whole lot it's a cosmetic line it's
everything's made from coconut oil and I
started with the lip gloss which I just
love I put it over all my matte lips and
it just makes it silky smooth and then I
got into their face mist and night and
face cream what a chick in Miami we're
in a room it was like a long weekend we
were over each other and Jackie couldn't
find her cool party and she was out here
accusing everyone of stealing Hooker
party and then her wrist also hurts she
was like who stole my cap re and who
snapped my wrist anyone's how are you
tiny was you you moves my cup re it was
no I didn't I just moved it like a
little bit you move my Campari no I did
and I just moved it but so a couple
weeks ago I was saying on the toast how
like my armpits have gotten so itchy
that like which is like isn't like the
biggest problem in the world but like
out in public I'm like itching my
armpits like a monkey you're not wearing
your being monkey so I started using KO
party children it's coconut it's
aluminum free it's vegan it doesn't have
any silicone sulfates parabens GMOs or
baking soda and I have to say the
itching has gone away the itching have
subsided and it smells so good it smells
like coconut it smell so good and it
also doesn't look like jeona and just
looks like this glam like right dick I
don't know natural deodorants can be a
scary thing I look like a nurse they
don't work usually right this one really
does so if you're in the market for a
natural deodorant went to a no good if
you watch Kardashians and you see
Kourtney Kardashian like up on the
stands like it actually isn't like the
chemicals that are in some of our
deodorants are [ __ ] wild because also
your glands are there so you don't want
to put the chemical with the cleanser I
think are important right
so cope re deodorant smells incredible
and it's all natural which is just so
winning and go to my love cope re go to
hary beauty.com / toast to make the safe
switch to deodorant today say five
dollars off your first order when you
subscribe that's cope re Kop a are a
beauty dot-com / toast cope re
beauty.com / toast that link is a dream
come true for me you know de jakke
like when they wanted to sponsor an
episode jackie was freaking out because
like she was a problem thirst monster
general whatever wouldn't have it any
other way no and you guys if you're not
on the Copart a-train he's together yeah
no actually it really has changed like
my my monkey like tendencies right and
you need a kapowee gloss over your lip
liner and they do bicep for life
actually this lip liner that I got does
come with a gloss let me just and then
let me just snap your wrist to make it
official relax
if you wanna get a close-up with me I
think you have to put on the bus like
you know yeah like Marilyn Monroe is
that mine no but you came in a PR
package it's a great stuff yeah it's a
nice color it's a duo no one wants to
know the name it's sex machine I think
fifth and final story speaking of beauty
and beauty standards and the impossible
standards set for women that you know
called set sex machines that Mattel is
attempting to change Oh Barbie is now in
a wheelchair and has a prosthetic leg
that's a weird headline okay now six
decades old Barbie is a lot different
than she used to be that is there's no
one way to look at Barbie now a far cry
was it one way to look at anyone a
couple years ago but I'm glad that
they're finally getting with the times
right and they've been leavin slowly not
they've been evolving and progressing a
lot recently and they're continuing to a
far cry from the disproportionate blonde
white woman she started off as Barbie
today is much shade with the article
from the dumb [ __ ] once was and they
talk about her like she's a person like
Barbies no longer at all this show that
Barbie shoe as you know that yes Barbara
Goldberg Barbie today is much more
representative of the young people who
play with her she still white and blonde
yes but thanks to Mattel's latest
addition to the Barbie fashionista line
she's also black brunette skinny curvy
and now in a wheelchair
patel's and has new additions to the
fashionista line on February 11th adding
Barbies with braided hair textures new
body types and
but where's redhead Barbie still no I'm
not seeing one wow they miss me amber
you guys what is this like everyone is
just like I'm so here for this
representation I can't even tell you but
it's just like a little weird it's like
a representation for everyone except
redheads though Mochis - there seems
like tension
it seems intentional like it's not that
much harder to add a redhead no well
good for Barbie for finally like
figuring it out Barbie will now have a
wheelchair and another dog will have a
removable prosthetic leg while the line
is added more than 100 new looks over
the past few years to make its stock
increasingly diverse like the young
people who play with Barbies the latest
additions are a direct response to what
Barbie fans want quote we're going to be
introducing a doll in a wheelchair and a
doll representing physical disabilities
she has a prosthetic limb Kymco mode
Mattel vice president of Barbie design
told team though there will be
additional body sizes of Barbie with
smaller bus and less defined waist a
wheelchair doll in a wheelchair or doll
in a wheelchair was one of the most
requested items to our customer hotline
it's important to us to listen to our
customers that is probably so cool like
to be a kid in a wheelchair like you
already feel like everyone like is you
just feel different and then just to
pick up a Barbie in a wheelchair that
probably feels awesome and honestly good
for Barbie this is cool I like this I
like this so much
I mean Barbie being Jewish like is funny
and highly unrealistic especially
considering the way they live in make a
leg wish justice for the girls for the
girls just streaming service to many
service streaming service streaming
service causes Kylie's classic Kylie's
closet Kylie's closet lots of money and
Happiness lots of money and happiness
lots of money and happiness lots of
money and happiness a nice wedding and I
sweating a nice wedding a nice wedding
everything goes right everything goes
right everything goes right everything
goes right
a few more pounds lost a few more pounds
awesome actually now the dress person
told me that's the nicest thing you
carry well anyone can hear it should
tell me not to lose any more weight I
was my dress mom fit Wow but like that's
she could say that to anyone I also
don't gain weight right true true hmm um
Barbie very nice except it's funny that
she's a Jewish girl and like she started
out as like at this tall Guinea like it
wasn't realistic these jobs are
contested it should have had like her
mom in the back yelling at her a little
bit of a beer belly you know right was
sick frizzy hair but also like American
girl did this like a while back
no American girl is so like ahead of
their game right but they're also like
really premium and expensive you know
and they come with all these artists I
should work for American Girl doll and
come up with dolls with origin stories
and dogs with arches
he's totally totally like kick hit REITs
in the 1920s surviving the great
defender when um Gaby gets a doll
because she's like trying to fill the
void of her birth biological whatever um
that's what American Girl doll is it's
like porcelain like really fancy those
dolls are like 300 bucks yeah and then
like all the the house the clothes the
glasses like it's an expensive hobby we
all got one when we were kids and like
it was the greatest day of our lives and
like mine was so ugly and eyeglasses and
frizzy hair and I was like really upset
because you took her braids out no we
all go bug off okay we got doll she had
Molly
we all got dolls that resembled us so it
was really easy forever into fireman but
mean Olivia like we're similar but just
like we're pale white brunettes so
Olivia got like the cooler one Samantha
Samantha and I got the nerd Molly with
braids and glasses and I was unhappy so
I tried to go for a change
I took her braids out I literally read
it under the water I literally tried to
Flatiron it and it was ruined and she
looked [ __ ] crazy but they were
expensive and I wasn't allowed to get
another one because I ruined it faster
like that defines you Jeff
yeah just like always feeling like
unlike there wasn't a place where maybe
if there was a fat Barbie I would have
felt better
ah far be Joseph I had kit kittredge and
who did snitch a Samantha no Olivia had
Smith oh I don't know it's just like a
little blonder like it was one that mean
Olivia had but like a little blonder cuz
Margot used to have like dirty blonde
hair interesante and then I loved my
American girl and then they came out
with an American girl baby like a
newborn and I got that too I had a
friend with like all the child she was
an only child so like all the toys that
like her whole toy but for the family
was hers you know she had all that she
liked the house the poop how scary is
she now
no totally actually she's really [ __ ]
smart right that's scary I'm sure no she
had a pool for her dolls
honestly I loved playing with dolls I
know but now it's like I don't even see
the door like whatsoever it's like it's
not real do you remember when we we said
like ice to have a collection of
porcelain dolls in my room just a few
like somewhat that were gifts but when
we were younger our parents had
porcelain dolls made of us like us
looking porcelain dolls were they I
don't know rich right where are they I
don't know I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure that I had a porcelain doll that
looked like that was me made after me
that's man Amanda been making that up
but we should look into it I don't
recall but I
a frizzy-haired American Girl doll and I
wasn't happy about it
my girl is like still like a thriving
business a big huge store I know I look
like the devil right so much real estate
it's like Gordon Taylor can stay in
business but American girls can they're
doing something right they are and so is
Barbie I'm here for all of this people
are there might be a redhead bar but eat
I need to look into it I want to talk to
you about something that's someone in
the comments just for my staff chef
tweed yes okay hold on let me pull it up
I was just strolling Twitter I do follow
Steph chef just cuz like she's cool and
pretty and why not um and she's always
like a retweeting good like social
justice things you know yeah okay so she
tweeted step chef she tweeted yesterday
I mean a lot of people don't know that
her boyfriend or her husband or like
partner he's like a huge executive at
Apple music I just she never needed like
the job like she's she's cool on her own
yeah but then she became even cooler
working for him yeah so after the
Grammys two nights ago she tweeted oh
sorry after the Grammys two nights ago
she had a party at her house I guess it
was like an apple music party she lives
in a huge house and then yesterday she
tweeted one of my childhood idols was at
my house for our Grammy party last night
I mean I wanted to be this woman she
inspired me to move to LA and work in
entertainment and she was so [ __ ]
rude to me in my own home what a bummer
and then Kim quote tweeted and was like
oh my god I know who you're talking
about I have no idea I mean there was no
pictures from this party so it's
literally virtually impossible to figure
out who it could be
I just like feel like it's Diana Ross oh
really I don't know because like someone
that she would have looked up to when
she was younger so like someone went
years ago and that was a mainstay at the
Grammys the other night well yeah
or maybe JLo yeah but other icons like
older icons were there um I'm trying to
Ollie Parton no way I'm trying to see if
people are guessing in the comments and
they're really not but I closed a nice
person Alicia Keys there's no way
there's no way he's an angel
there's no way there's literally no way
maybe it was Diana Ross Blake she can be
mean and it was like her night you know
yeah but I guess it's like when you're
in someone's house like be nice to the
host but if Kim was like I know it is
Kim has friends with JLo so maybe Kim
wouldn't be like fueling the fire
because like forever end so maybe it's
not JLo and yeah and Kim just must know
who stabbed chapter like was obsessive
right
this was kept via chemists responses oh
I know who this is emoji with the hand
on the face it's really annoying a lot
of people are saying taillow a lot of
people are saying SJP was she at the
Grammys I don't know it's just so
interesting it's interesting factoids
that are full of interesting did you
watch Vanderpump rules I did it was
nothing episode nothing they didn't get
to solve until like the last 10 minutes
and it's like what they teased on the
preview is the one of you last minute of
Kristin like being ladies give us
anything no there's nothing to talk
about it was literally an hour like
there the whole episode was there 25
minutes on the private jet I mean the
whole the whole episode was nothing
except for when they were going through
the rooms and they like did room 1 2 3
and then they went to Sheena's room and
they like zoomed all the way out of the
hotel she's in room 6 oh it was really
funny actually felt really bad for her
when they were just like okay cuz like
it really she was like normally I'll be
rooming with Ariana and the Ariana's
room is Stasi like that's crazy that's
crazy also I mean I don't understand why
these girls in house I was like don't
realize that rooming alone is the
greatest gift no she knows like I mean I
live alone like I want it when I'm on
vacation I want to be with somebody I'm
like what what no like if I were Lala I
planned the trip I'd be like that means
I get to be alone thing was yellow with
Britney yeah and then Stasi
didn't know it seems like it should have
been
ariana scheana Katie Stassi Britney
Kristen Lala's on room yeah but like
Kristen's own room because she said
crazy yes she was being so crazy but I'm
actually spoke to her cuz we were DMing
and she like she's she's like doing what
Chloe Trotman doing that she's owning
the fact like these episodes like she's
like embarrassed 7 like she'll sit stand
by her behavior you know but in general
I've been feeling her because she's a
lot more normal yeah but like when she
like left her purse when you're going on
a trip like I'm sorry but she's 37 years
old like what is being such a bad
traveler entail I would understand
Stassi means so annoyed like Stassi she
left without her
totally but Stassi like kept bringing it
up and like being a [ __ ] like I totally
understood why I like that would bother
me so much especially just cuz Stassi
was like the only one who hasn't been on
a private jet before she was like so
excited and she's lost like 30 minutes
waiting for everyone because she was
waiting right she should have left
without her and not let it spoil her
time Kristen's obviously but then they
had that conversation about Carter so
maybe she's like going through something
through yeah but I feel like the
conversation she was having with Carter
like didn't seem alarming to me at all
that's a
very normal relationship problems when
you're living together right of chores
and your boyfriend called you
overbearing okay yeah and like you don't
want to take the dogs out like totally
I'm better than her being like psycho
and all the other things like made out
with a girl in Vegas you know right
there are worse problems out those are
normal couples issues I think her and
Carter all right like definitely legit
yeah too good feeling about them me too
I just wish they gave us more and I just
want to say solving looks sad as [ __ ]
right and Lala doesn't even drink and I
mean I'm glad they finally addressed the
fact that she doesn't drink anymore
I wanted more from the story about break
a pretty window proof window I don't
know where were they who are they with
window obviously there's more to the
story but I'm glad that she like
addressed it and I feel like she's happy
to talk about it like Bravo like won't
air and they didn't even dress until
this episode that she's not drinking did
she drink in Seoul they know why did
they go there well obviously if you
charter a plane for 25 minutes it's a
lot cheaper than chartering a plane for
four hours to Mexico like yeah they must
have just that charter can't couldn't
have cost more than like 20 grand which
for Randall is not a lot no and does his
own cleaning know he charters every
charters he should just get one it's
really expensive and like it's not even
the buying of the plane it's the
maintenance of the plane like the type
of person who can charter a plane and
the type of person who owns a plane like
the difference in money is like hundreds
of millions of dollars that's crazy at
the Kardashians don't have a plane man I
know but it doesn't it doesn't make
sense because they would not be able to
only one person available to use it at a
time if they all splitted they're all
always in different places they wouldn't
be able the schedule would be so stupid
they would still be chartering because
Carly's using it like that doesn't make
any sense yeah yeah chartering I think
is the way to go and you have to park it
in [ __ ] yeah interesting interesting
unless here's the level of money where
like literally like you [ __ ] out ten
million dollars which there are people
you don't need a plane you charter that
Erica Jean has two planes
oh yeah her husband yeah interesting I
heard about that um anyways I'm just I
love LA LA so much and when Lisa was
like being salty because they were
talking about the plane and first of all
Lala wasn't one the one who said it like
when Lisa was like
longing to come back she's acting like I
work for her she like Lala was being
cute and going to her boss like can we
have the day off we covered our ships
please indulge in this fantasy that we
they think we still think they need to
ask for time off right but like then she
was being that way she respect
and an employee and she was just me
we're gonna see a girl stoop like she
wasn't being like throwing into her face
at all Sheena was the one who said it so
like Lisa wanted to die when they said
it I know and I think an wala wanted to
die too because I think while I know she
makes Lisa uncomfortable with the fact
that she's on her level yeah on she was
just like bringing herself she was
grounding herself being like please
going on this trip we covered her shifts
and everything yes she did you played
the role that Lisa wanted her to play
Sheena [ __ ] it up and Lisa was like so
animala yeah it's really like that was
an awkward scene the right please let me
please stay over and sleep island yeah
it was so that she was just so oblivious
yeah I really like I can't with Lisa
she's really getting to me but I
cambogia drunk it's funny how like in
literally like 10 yo she's been on TV
like I've never seen her drunk they
didn't even put it in the episode last
week that would have been interesting
finally no we have to see Lisa with the
restaurant in Ken and the job suite to
see the most boy um yeah there was
boring [ __ ] the gas the electricity but
no one time she's finally interesting
drunk we don't get in an episode we get
like a 10-second flashback in the next
week yes [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] really
boring episode like I couldn't believe
that they would just tease just so much
when it was a it was this is two weeks
now so it's e3 and they literally just
got to solving and I'm like what they're
going through the rooms I'm like what it
was two weeks of boring episodes and it
just makes me feel like there's not much
more I need to talk about how literally
James his whole family's thirsting for a
spinoff it's so annoying like I don't
want his brother to work there I don't
want to hear about his mom like it's so
uninteresting mom is so how out of
control like yeah I thought when she
when they were fighting like I thought
she like she definitely is you know
going through it and James like is
helping her and it's not appreciating
all the things that she did for him way
back when whatever but when she like
went ELISA and Lisa was just like what
are you doing here like huh like it was
so inappropriate it was sort of like
that she's setting these said to take
care to employ her whole family totally
and and James asking her just to not
talk speak ill of her dad in front his
dad in front of him is such a reasonable
thing and I think that's something like
kids have divorced definitely all are
like their parents are fighting like
can't even keep the kids out of it kids
take sides like it's such an aura it was
a very normal and reasonable request of
him just to be like can you stop talking
[ __ ] about dad in front of me like it's
annoying he's still my dad and she was
just like so nuts Tiffany's Ralph Lauren
that doesn't a good mom
agreed also I will never forgive or
forget what she said about Kristen being
barren when they broke up and she was
like I hope she's barren she comes on
the show every now and then and she just
says horrible things but I couldn't
agree more that is something like even
on my worst worst enemy I would
literally never in my life wish or hope
or more even things to say especially
about like a young girl who at one point
loved your son totally it's just a bite
let's be real
Kristen is responsible for James 1,000%
but everything changed up the money that
James is sending to his mom originates
from Kristen he never would have been on
the show Kristen gave you made him a
primary character like and yes he did a
good job on the show for sure but
and that's why Kristen hates him so much
she made him into the monster that he is
right
Christine is responsible for all of
James success you have to at least give
her that I and I do give her that so for
his mom to say that like even everything
she's doing now in the episode it's just
like you know bad behavior not a big
deal I'll forget about it but I will
never forget that and that's why I will
never feel sorry for her she's she said
she's cursed she's barren yes that she
will be that's an evil thing to say evil
about just a young girl a young girl
yeah we need Kristen's crazy she's a
crazy ex-girlfriend but like to wish
that on someone is long gone
so that's how I feel about her um I
didn't watch The Bachelor but I did get
a DM cuz I've just ever since I found
out who went I'm just like someone
interested someone to me they were like
the spoiler that reality Steve had he
just changed what yeah I don't know if
it's true I don't want to read the whole
thing because I just didn't want to get
more spoilers but I have a feeling I
might not know what I think I know oh
that's good
when I was watching last night's episode
it really turned everything on his head
of what I thought to be true like first
of all I thought he was over Hannah J no
I thought he meant that Hannah G and
Cassie like when I was watching the
middle of it episode I was like oh those
will be the final two people like that
hello choose between but I don't think
so
first of all kirpa I like she is she was
reminding me of Catherine Giudices she
got a really late one-on-one but there's
a connection of course and I could see
her winning seriously like she was just
so relaxed she just she is it completely
like Hannity and Cassie I'm sorry are
kind of the same idea I'm same person
she was just completely different energy
and I could see her winning and I was
just like I all I could think back with
she was Katherine Giudice she literally
was the last one on Monday you know a
throw away and she was just a totally
different kind of energy than Sean had
met before and she was the one also
gently tone the comments I believe there
was a spoiler okay I'm just I'm trading
my phone off yeah justice her Demi she's
so precious I know and I was like I
don't know if she's the greatest actress
of all time or if I'm truly heartbroken
no I mean it's so funny cuz like you see
someone on TV you think you know them
but it's like Korean like if you would
have you just believed what used to saw
about her on TV it's like she's crazy
did you meet her in life in like she's
so cute and precious and like she gets
her feelings hurt too you know and
that's why I think about Tammy like she
didn't mean to see me she's crazy Burger
goes for sex but she's like a sweet
little precious little nut and it's like
clear that some hurting sir was like go
tell colder than how you feel about him
and then like it's just totally sucked
in that moment she just knew like she
got played she played herself and then
when she was like he was breaking up
with her and she was like not crying she
was just like touching her face and then
when he hugged her and so she's behind
his back and she starts crying like it
was just so sad
well how many girls at home last night
at five because we've got rid of the two
in the beginning we had in three midway
we it's you in the beginning Demi Demi
the girl who sent her self album the NBA
dancer I don't even know her and then
the girl with the lips who Katie didn't
know her so beautiful
she was short who is uh other I'm
talking about what do you mean like
everyone's saying who is right
I think it's Kailyn I think their talk
no they keep showing everyone they're
talking about a lot of people they're
talking about Hannah be Kailyn Cassie
they keep showing Cassie they're not
showing Heather em no they're not and
they're not really showing Hannah gee it
did seem like they were talking about
one person specifically it seemed like
they were talking about the whole bunch
cuz all these girls are the same are
like copies of each other had Jin Queen
reality baby then when the two old wise
ones are like it's gonna be us at the
end who said that
Taoiseach and kirpa said they were being
really weird at the end they were like
watch how it's just the two of us here
let me tell you she was definitely
normal Taoiseach is vital for material
I thought that I was like but then I was
getting villian material it's like all
that they said that that's all together
so in front of all the other girls and
they were like wait what it was weird
but maybe there's something we don't
know like their connections are so
obvious I don't know I don't know it was
a lot of subliminal he didn't jump off
the wall yet but I think he tweeted last
night that he jumps off the wall he
jumps off the wall next week and I'm
just I'm so it's a I need to know next
week's episode looks really crazy but
everything they do that with every
episode where sessional and girls are
crying and no makeup crying and you know
in backs of cars and but I feel like
maybe the episode suck really would be
there is a lot of drama in every episode
imagine if it was one hour they would be
drama packed like great but it spans
over two hours something that happened
two hours ago is no longer crazy you
know yeah I just can't believe that
Hanabi is still there like to me she
seems insane I know like and Colton like
but not in an evil way just like in a
weird way yeah like a weirdo but maybe
it's just she's like one of those weird
funny people and it's just not
translating on television that happened
where she's when she's like doing karate
with her split yeah she work it out fit
to the cocktail party I'll give her to
the group dude where are they now they
were in Vietnam and then I don't know
where they go next week it's been a nice
season I've actually been rather
enjoying it and I really like them and
while I thought that Cassie one just
based on you know what they have
together and the way people talk about
her now you're saying it changes I
really don't know so then they show that
Hannah B makes it to hometowns
I believe that Heather makes it to
hometowns okay Hannah be Heather because
they're kissing he's kissing Heather
like outside what looks to be a train
track I feel like the fact that Cassie's
family is like being written up
everywhere do you see the cactus family
blonde here's her sister isn't actress
who dates Gregg Sulkin like I feel like
we're definitely gonna get a hometown
from her yes just cuz it's interesting
her family so then the four the fourth
person I take SHINee Hana G when would
he send her home yet tisha tisha Hanna G
or kirpa oh wow I'm telling her but like
it's not to be ignored but maybe they
didn't really spoil it maybe what they
saw was like he G he took her home and
left her there you know no but I'm
saying maybe what you saw wasn't a home
do no but she literally no maybe what I
saw was Heather wasn't a home town but
with Hannah be she literally goes calls
and meet my family and they're all there
but maybe it's a surprise
I don't know they're always you know
throwing things at us
yeah Monday nights are just so hard for
TV like it just it never ends I know but
then it's like I really got through it
all I didn't watch what happens live
because I was doing my tables so like I
didn't want to rush I got a lead on it I
don't know okay even live but it's still
the pre-recorded la ones I think oh then
I wonder how long maternity leave and
he's kind of Jake he can take as long as
he wants but like I miss him
yeah but you have us but we don't have
us
okay what else does CSU key is on
tonight tomorrow we had Melissa Gorga
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
premieres tonight it does yeah gird your
loins gird your [ __ ] loins oh
my god wait I just canceled my dinner
yeah no I'm literally gonna cancel it
yeah and then siesta key which I have to
be home for woke up on us cuz I have to
watching the MTV app lies like Joe you
just use the screener also we get it
then it's a screener on top and I watch
on my computer and they are no joke to
me I want them on my TV yeah
holy [ __ ] I can't believe Beverly Hills
is on tonight literally like I'm so
excited using the tag lines all the code
for the tag lines and the New Jersey
finale its finale isn't is tonight it's
tonight tomorrow it's tonight yeah yeah
so Melissa's on tomorrow no I'm sorry
get to now tomorrow Wednesday to finales
tomorrow oh my god I can't wait to talk
to Melissa hold on and then it's like I
want to talk to Melissa about the season
and we get screeners but I don't want to
talk about an episode that you guys
haven't seen yet no and I haven't been
watching the screeners I like what you
neither but I want to what like it's
like we're not gonna be able to talk to
her about the finale because we wouldn't
whatever okay here are the tag lines
ready
by the way when they're all standing
with the diamonds there are so many of
them there's seven I ask you like that's
a lot that's a lot it'll be six when
Lisa goes yeah and six is a good amount
okay Lisa Rinna I believe has the best
one in the game of life it's Rinna take
all a plus a [ __ ] plus Erika Girardi
most people talk about their fantasies
I'm living mine a minus B plus it's
better than an enigma wrapped in a
riddle and cash
and it explains exactly who she is it's
good for everyone but I just expect a
lot from her just cuz she is this
creative genius yeah to read Kemsley in
business and in life I wear many hats
and hairstyles love making funny babies
out of herself love loves but like a -
you but like you can't just decide
you're a businesswoman
like I'm sorry that really beach fighter
you I need to order something just to
make sure the quality's there but I'm
loving it Lucy Vanderpump you can stab
me in the back but whilst you're there
kiss my ass a because that's exactly
what's going on her tag lines are always
like six resonant you even throw me to
the wolves but I'll return leading the
pack
right after you know everyone ganged up
on her oh well they're always pertinent
to the situation that is an a and that
it's like people are stabbing her in the
back so she feels and she does have a
nice ass
teddy Mellencamp Patrick who's that
stassi's teddy Mellencamp hey plus plus
I'm not afraid of hard work but I'll
never do your dirty work because that's
what Lisa Vanderpump wanted her to do it
100% I think this is what I think
happens in the beginning the jury dog
thing happens it's just hard for me when
you like Ryan work with work but up I
know so I'm gonna get the problem with
my Housewives headline this is my house
on tagline yeah I may be short and round
you cannot push me around but I'm
writing it rhyming round with rounds
right it does make sense yeah feel free
to do so we need to crystallize our our
tag lines yeah I don't like that like I
don't really have one
you guys toaster master Fred may be a
type I may be I may be short and stout
who wants about this pout that's good no
I think it's like such as we don't
really have look good let's if we got
that together every lace bra go super
fan has there I may wear dirty jeans but
I won't air my dirty laundry well but
then I'm saying dirty and dirty I think
it's fine that's good that's pretty good
okay no you
someone once said it's hard to start it
without it with anything I may well see
if they start my problems in bed in New
York City I wash my hands in New York
City I got the biggest cities oh okay
like watch if I hit in business and in
life that's how they start you you can
like it's hard yeah I mean it's a common
phrases and then like we're gonna take
off yeah that's so good okay Denise
horrible my problem with the tabloids my
real life is so much juicier see see as
someone who has like a lifetime of
experience and knowledge to draw
yeah this is horrible and honestly she's
out of the tabloids that much that's why
she's on the show now and it's it should
be like my ex-husband is Charlie Sheen
I can handle crazy ya know like you
think you're crazy
I was married to Charlie Sheen that
would be epic
yeah there's nothing I can't handle I
was married to Charles Jean for the
final I can't they get high all the last
one they usually do Lisa opens it life
isn't all diamonds and rose a but it
should be a P shut up there yeah Kyle in
Beverly Hills the truth always has a way
of rising to the top love love and I
think that I think she's last because
that's something I want to leave us with
while we watch the season oh so I don't
think Kyle has ever had a tag line where
she didn't mention Beverly Hills yeah no
um I work too hard for this zip code to
go home now it's a desperate tag I'm not
in Beverly Hills it's easy to spot a
fake yeah or some [ __ ] like that work
she'll be like in Beverly Hills these
Ania
yeah no she really you're really saying
Beverly Hills I wouldn't Beverly whoo
that's it my address is no no - what up
come rob me no actually someone did
Garrett someone I read on Twitter she
moved to that new house which is
actually in Encino it's not in Beverly
Hills so she can't really say anymore oh
my god so now she's tore up everything
else from a distance yeah for people in
Beverly Hills they tell the truth
I hear it's easy to spot a fake in
Beverly Hills but I don't know cuz I
don't live there cuz I didn't see no the
house is so nice I actually loved her
incertum story she should move this
house has that dude it has been juju but
she always like highlights the house in
like a cute way like what Gina was like
little twinkly lights outside I love her
house
I don't follow her you don't know it's
interesting the house I was at youth
house it's not even my favorite
housewives the only house eyes that I
follow are obviously Erika Jayne who is
a favorite housewife and you know her
Condon's mom for as premium as it should
be it's a lot of tore promo partnerships
she's doing up not enough to discuss
sitting in on her lounge chair outside
like living her life yeah I need more of
that dream premium [ __ ] content all
day every day hair in spoken for -
Leeanne vibes
like she she gets it Lisa Rinna's is
good because she like pokes fun at
herself she dances she does the kid the
Delilah Belle Amelia of it all she hurts
is good I don't follow her anymore but I
think that I should I used to follow
Tinsley but it wasn't premium she uses
weird Instagram filters Kyle's is good
because she's always like hanging out
with interesting people like Paris or
Kris Jenner
she also I was following her because she
got new teeth and I just wanted to
follow along and she said and I never
realized it before him before she got
her teeth done she's like I never smiled
with my mouth open
now she's she's in everywhere and I
follow I think I thought was the most
from New Jersey they say none of us has
the worst Instagram of all time it is so
it's all about her wine I think Pandora
runs it it's so much a sells fit tea so
it's like it's how rich can you get that
chanel purple croc totally they're
selling I mean maybe it's the baggage TT
but it's weird I always find it weird
when like housewives are supposed to be
this like illusion of like they're like
these rich fancy like this less style we
just want to have and then when they're
found selling fit tea it's like but how
you know or why yeah who doesn't I don't
think Erika Jayne does but she does a
lot of paid SEP she does a beauty
blender and toothpaste and like that I
think is more so for the building of her
brand like a.j and lifestyle brand it's
in it is the money agreed but also she's
getting paid like a quarter of a million
dollars like for everything she does
minimum yes an add-on Lisa Vanderpump's
Instagram she can't be taking anything
less than five thousand dollars like why
does she need that like for the Erika
Jayne it's really not about the money
look at something fishy about Lisa
Vanderpump's financials her life and
like just something about like she shows
up with this chanel that could kill me
sometimes but other than that like
everything's a little like costume yeah
and it's like before Bravo what were her
restaurants cuz like wouldn't Villa
Blanca was season one I remember going
was empty like it was before her
restaurants were like a thing now I
understand how she's making money but
she was a restaurant tour like in London
it's just also shade but remember her
old house like it was new Jane and like
this house that she lives in now the
Raza is amazing but it was a downside it
was like I remember when I saw it first
that's like that's miniature I'm like
they're having money problems right but
now it seems like the biggest house ever
I need to go watch the first season oh
my god she lived in the same gated
community as Adrienne Maloof who also
had like the craziest house with the
Lions outside then I'll huff yeah and
there's this new series on Netflix
called Kardashian the man who made a Jay
Simpson or whatever and the picture is
Adrienne Maloof what you're you must
have be having like a [ __ ] up TV no
like Marie Kondo did you see them yes oh
my god hold up what is the name of the
the show Kardashian the man who saved Oh
Jay something like that
the man or maybe it's Faye Resnick and I
think they look alike my but I don't
think so I know what they dream look I
know that Maloof hoof okay on on Google
the picture that comes up is like an
old-school picture of him and OJ in
court
oh my god you're right on IMDB its
Adrienne Maloof hold on what do you have
to do with it they must have gotten
their photos wrong hey you know she's in
it she's in the man who saved OJ that's
what it is so what is she did she even
know the Kardashians like let me find
out give me a second okay the Adrienne
Maloof of it all oh there's nothing
maybe I should watch it yeah she's on it
watching you guys I'll report back okay
that's all we got make sure to watch oh
wait hold on
make sure to watch siesta key and
Beverly Hills tonight cuz we will be
recapping in depth tomorrow while also
talking to one of our favorite guests
Melissa Gorga I'm sorry Melissa Gorga
you know I'm like having and uh you're
so nervous about your show maybe it's
acid reflux maybe also while she's
pulling it up morning to us patreon.com
slash morning toast for extra premium
content this month is gonna be super
steamy and I have to be honest the
episode that we recorded yesterday maybe
because I talked the whole time I think
it's my favorite or the nice change for
you and I'm glad to like it's like
writing down history like I'm glad that
we will have these archives because I -
even though I have that memory that's a
steel track I think you - that I -
forget I to boot a I - Barthe okay if
you're in the morning toasters group the
Foxwoods
second show Late Show has been posted as
the Dallas second show has been added
VIP tickets are available I believe I'm
gonna post it on my Twitter - so if
you're not in the group hit it up done
um and then I'll also post in my
Instagram in a minute but that'll take
longer name I won't make you guys wait
around for that so yes if you have a
question for Melissa Gorga leave a
comment on our Instagram when we post a
photo of her we will do our best to get
it to her jersey finale tomorrow siesta
key and Beverly Hills tonight I can't
believe Everly Hills is on it literally
just snuck up on me like that and I
remember when the trailer came out I was
like this is never gonna happen like I
hate when they do that like it feels
like you know it's like next year at
school right like I won't ever make it
to the seventh grade no and I was like
when that trailer comes when it
premieres like I'm gonna basically be
that's my wedding yeah so like it's my
wedding a kid so I've just been relating
the this premiere to my wedding so my
wedding is here and it premieres tonight
oh my god so exciting okay we'll see us
tomorrow when we're probably gonna look
a whole lot different because our lives
are gonna be changed I just have a
feeling yeah
bye bye
you